[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
premier numéro du 7-8 sport sur tb 78
aujourd'hui nous sommes au golf de
vêtements pour parler du trophée à sport
passion c'est parti pour le sommaire
golf aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur
le trophée sport passion une compétition
de golf amical qui permet des sportifs
de haut niveau de jouer ensemble cette
année l'ancien patineur artistique
philippe candeloro était le parrain de
l'événement
jo-2020 poissy à célébrer le retour des
triathlètes de la ville médaillés à
tokyo cet été dorian conax 400 beaugrand
et l'oni père y ont reçu la médaille de
la commune course à pied ils ont
souffert ce samedi 11 septembre à
l'occasion de la diac 78 des trailer en
traverser le département des yvelines du
nord au sud dans des conditions pas
toujours simple reportage
[Musique]
nous sommes donc à la 28e édition du
trophée un sport passion qui mieux que
régine gandolfini pour nous parler de ce
trophée un sport passion vous est la
fondatrice bonjour régine bonjour oui un
trophée que j'ai créée en
1994 à la première édition était en 1994
au code de feucherolles et nous en
sommes cette année à la 28e édition est
ce que vous réalisez 28 éditions quand
même
je réalise en voyant les participants
qui étaient là aux premières éditions et
que je retrouve cette année alors
certains ne sont pas venus très
régulièrement d'autres sont venus très
fidèlement chaque année mais c'est à ce
moment là que je me dis mince ça fait
longtemps qu'on se connaît et c'est du
bonheur de se retrouver et on sent que
il ya vraiment une très forte amitié qui
existe en fait entre les sportifs qui
sont venus assez régulièrement au
trophée et moi et voilà ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir qu'il soit là et le
concept c'est quoi finalement alors le
concept c'est toujours le même depuis la
création à l'origine ce que je
souhaitais c'était réunir des sportifs
de haut niveau sur un golf leur
permettre de se retrouver et d'échanger
à cette époque là il n'y avait pas les
réseaux sociaux instagram n'y avait pas
tout ça ce qui veut dire que certains
sportifs ne rencontrait jamais d'autres
sportifs s'il n'était pas dans les mêmes
régions ou si il y en a qui faisait des
sports d'hiver d'audi sport d'été donc
l'idée c'était
unir des sportifs de haut niveau toutes
disciplines confondues
donc il pouvait y avoir des footballeurs
du psg comme il pouvait y avoir
sébastien flûte du tir à l'arc de les
faire jouer et de faire remporter un
sport donc c'est un sport qui gagne le
trophée sport passion chaque année et
c'est à la meilleure des deux bâle 1
c'est ça ils sont deux par équipe et
c'est la meilleure des deux ballons on
est d'accord at il joué en scramble ce
qui veut dire qu'il serait bien sûr une
équipe de deux et le second bol c'est il
se replace à chaque coup à l'emplacement
de la meilleure des deux bâle et il
avance à deux en équipe ce qui permet à
un joueur qui n'est peut-être pas très
bon associée à un meilleur joueur de
faire quand même un bon résultat à la
remise des prix le soir oui ça permet
d'équilibrer ses salles et lé débat et
puis ça permet aussi par exemple je
pense à sarah daninthe qui est
aujourd'hui sur le parcours elle débute
enfin des buts elles jouent pas très
régulièrement donc à joue pas forcément
très bien et je les mises à l'ex-romain
va-t-elle qui est un grand golfeur que
qui a fait donc des tournois
internationaux et jouent ensemble qui
fait qu' elle se sent confortée à
rassurer et lui il est très heureux de
jouer avec une sportive de haut niveau
il ya plein d'histoires autour de ce
trophée sport passion alors je crois
savoir que ces animations sur les
terrains mais également après on est
d'accord alors c'est le golfe bien sûr
donc le golf la compétition le golfe
l'initiation puisque ceux qui débutent
il ya beaucoup de sportifs de haut
niveau qui joue pas au golf donc on les
invités ils font l'initiation l'après
midi et puis pour permettre de découvrir
d'autres sports on a fait appel à
l'association ufolep donc le sport pour
tous qui vient chaque année maintenant
nous à nous installer des animations
donc on a un mur d'escaladé qui est
juste là on a une animation de football
de dice dance etc et il ya du poker
l'après midi et ce soir donc on affirme
candeloro qui est le parrain de
l'édition 2021 avec michel-ange marica
listes qui ont décidé de nous faire une
soirée dansante donc tout ça avec leur
caisse de gwendal peizerat le champion
olympique de danse sur glace que du beau
monde a ri et s'il y en a un également
qui a participé paiement de trophée
sport passion c'est karl olive car le
livre justement qui est juste derrière
karl olive vous pouvez venir le maire de
poissy vous adorez trophée sport passion
moi je suis surtout un homme d'amitié et
régine vandamme fini depuis une
trentaine d'années
voilà on se suit on se suit dans la
passion de régine qui est finalement
d'irradier par le sport évidemment quand
on est sportif et et je le suis depuis
que je suis gamin il ya forcément des
chemins qui nous permet de nous
retrouver donc c'est le cas maintenant
depuis 28 ans et comme je le disais moi
je suis ravie qu'aujourd'hui le
département des yvelines puissent
valoriser le sport passion parce que
c'est pas simplement un événement je
dirais sur la forme il ya beaucoup de
symbolique qui qui s'y retrouve
notamment avec des champions olympiques
qui sont là c'est peut-être des gens qui
se seraient pas connues si on n'avait
pas organisé ce type de ce type
d'événement mais il ya aussi je le
disais et c'est très important l'humain
au coeur de nos organisations ça nous
manque c'est aujourd'hui dans nos
sociétés et régine a toujours été cette
personne qui a irradié justement par
cette générosité par cette amitié et sa
pas toujours été simple parce que 28 ans
c'est à la fois court essai et c'est
long et on sait qu'aujourd'hui pour
justement rendre possible parfois se
considère comme comme impossible il faut
avoir vraiment je dirais la foi
chevillée au corps vous avez vu les
premières éditions de ce trophée sport
passion comment vous l'avez vu évoluer
en 71 28 dernières années or le paradoxe
de la situation c'est que finalement ça
évolue je dirais avec le nombre de
participants mais ça n'a jamais varié
d'une seule virgule parce que c'est ce
que ce à quoi tient régime sur les
fondements qui sont être sérieux sans se
prendre au sérieux j'ai presque envie de
dire que vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est
l'été indien ici à poissy pour cette 28e
édition mais quand vous voyez les
sourires quand vous voyez c'est ces
championnes et ses champions qui blague
ensemble on a l'impression qu'ils ont
toujours vécu 5 min 5 mini réseau
olympique qu'on retrouve ici et ça c'est
formidable parce que j'aime à dire que
les plus grands sont les plus simples et
que évidemment seul on va plus vite mais
ensemble on va plus loin alors on disait
qu'il y avait pas mal d'histoires au
delà du trophée sport passion à ce que
vous avez des anecdotes peut-être à nous
raconter sur ce trophée sport passion je
me souviens qu'avec jean galfione dans
les premières éditions en prenant un
malin plaisir en arrivant comme ça sur
les greens de mettre la balle avec la
tête et avec le puck dans les trous je
me souviens aussi de troisième mi-temps
qui était particulièrement bien arrosée
ce n'était pas simplement un moment où
il fallait partir mais plutôt rester
pour être tranquille le matin et pas
être inquiété et ça ça fait partie aussi
du bonheur d des sportifs il faut jamais
boudé son plaisir la vie je pensais est
trop courte pour se prendre au sérieux
et c'est aussi le message je crois que
régine fait passer à toutes celles et
ceux qui veulent participer d'abord à ce
port passion alors 28e édition est ce
qu'il y en aura d'autres régimes
gandolfini j'imagine que oui répond je
réponds d'origine attendez on n'est pas
parti avec le département des yvelines
dans dans ce beau territoire pour
laisser régine sur sur le côté ça fait
28 ans quelques elle encore une fois
retrousse ses manches et régine mon
petit doigt me dit qu en 2024 elle sera
là et bien là et qu'on sera avec elle si
tout va bien voilà vous confirmez régine
et oui on voit la 30e édition ensemble
et voilà j'espère que ce sera encore une
très très belle fête avec beaucoup de
sportifs qui qui qui qui sont on va dire
entre guillemets à la retraite mais
aussi énormément de sportifs on a des on
a des samir aït saïd par exemple qui
était le porte drapeau rouge voiture au
monde c'est finalement est en tête
affiche en activité ce qui est important
aussi c'est environ 50% des sportifs qui
sont là sont les sportifs en activité et
donc parfois un peu moins connu un peu
moins sur un peu moins des stars on va
dire mais en tout cas ce sont des grands
sportifs alors ici on est au golf de
bêtement ça a été fait pendant 27 ans au
golf de feucherolles vous avez eu envie
de changer c'est ça une année peut-être
de revenir peut-être plus tard aux
gaffes de fécherolle oui bien sûr je
crois qu'on a fait
26e année sur les 28 au golf de
feucherolles parce que c'est là que
j'avais créé le golf le trophée avec le
directeur du golf de ce choc donc je la
fidélité elle était aussi par rapport au
golf c'était important pour moi d'être
fidèle au golf une année on n'avait pas
assez de place à feucherolles on était
allé à saint nom la bretèche et les
sportifs m'ont dit non non non on est
mieux un fol donc on est revenu à
feucherolles et puis cette année à
l'occasion des changes avec karl avec
philippe candeloro qui est le paradis
mais pourquoi on ferait pas une fois a
bêtement qui est juste à côté et
finalement on s'est dit mais pourquoi
pas puisque c'est le même groupe c le
groupe you golf qui a le golf de se
frôler le goal de vêtements et ils ont
eu la gentillesse de déplacer une
personne deux squales pour venir
travailler avec nous aujourd'hui a
bêtement donc je les en remercie
vraiment comment vous le trouvez ce golf
justement magnifique magne vous plaît à
baie magnifique au niveau de la de la
configuration pour toutes les animations
qu'on a mise en place et c'est vrai que
c'était un nouveau vol dans c'était
difficile pour nous de d'avoir de tous
et nos marques mais très très bien pour
les animations qu'on met donc à
l'extérieur les joueurs ont l'air de
dire que le parcours il est magnifique
moi je n'ai pas encore joué
et la restauration je n'ai que des écho
extrêmement positif sur la restauration
ils me disent waouh donc on est très
contents d'être là cette année merci
beaucoup à régine gandolfini on va aller
maintenant voir les résultats du
week-end c'est bixente mairie on sentit
steban qui nous les dévoile on est parti
pour les résultats du week-end à la
fiche la victoire de tony yoka face à
pétard millas pour le retour de la boxe
à roland garros 50 ans après le poids
lourd originaire de chanteloup les
vignes s'est défait de son adversaire au
bout de la septième reprise après des
débuts jugés trop passif par les experts
il a su se ressaisir et mettre ko le
croate millas sur un bel enchaînement
une onzième victoire de suite pour le
français dans sa course pour devenir une
légende en football de la nationale 3 à
présent avec un derby le montois fc a
vaincu sur ses terres le club des
mureaux 1 0 un succès à domicile de
l'équipe de mantes-la-jolie qui pointe à
la cinquième place du classement après
trois journées les mureaux sont eux à la
10e position c'est à la reprise en
régionale 2 nov le prochain train s'est
facilement défait du combo voix sport
quatre buses un autre pensionnaire
yvelinois de la division le oui à ses
vainqueurs sur la pelouse tiny en
essonne 2 à 0 les deux clubs se
positionne donc en haut du classement il
y avait également du handball ce
week-end c'était la reprise dans le
championnat de nationale 2 féminine en
quête d'une montée en fin de saison
montigny le bretonneux débute par une
défaite face à plouagat le score 28 à 24
après cette première journée lésigny
montaigne sont à la 10e place du
classement elles joueront ce samedi à
domicile contre ostende du finistère
toujours au rang de balle mais cette
fois ci dans le championnat de nationale
3 ce samedi 11 septembre le derby entre
couilles le vésinet carrière et plaisir
les clés s'est soldé par une victoire
des locaux le score est sans appel 25 à
20 au classement où le vésinet carrière
est à la cinquième position et plaisir
les clés à la 10e place voilà ce qu'on
pouvait lire michael sur les résultats
sportifs de cette semaine on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
flash résultat on continue cette
émission par deux personnalités à de
renom qui sont ici sur les greens de ce
golf de bêtement il y a tout d'abord
christophe jallet l'ancien joueur du
paris saint germain qui participe
aujourd'hui à ce trophée sport passion
et il y a philippe candeloro qui est
avec eux également qui est le parrain de
cette 28e édition alors déjà philippe
parent 28e édition c'était logique ben
en fait moi c'est ma vingtième
participation sur les 28 et ce avec un
grand bonheur que j'ai accepté de
devenir le parrain de cette 28e édition
parce que régine me l'a demandé et
régine vandall fini quand elle vous
demande quelque chose vous pouvez pas
refuser et qu'est ce que c'est d'être
parrain du coup d'être parent c'est pas
grand chose de plus que d'être simple
invité et puis joueurs on est là on fait
un petit mot d'accueil on dit bonjour
aux gens ont fait passer quelques petits
films vidéo qui vous rappellent les
vingt ans passés au sein de sport
passion des trophées sport passion et
puis voilà ces histoires de aussi de
passer la main parce qu'il ya plein de
nouveaux sportifs des jeunes sportifs
qui arrivent parce que régine essaie de
renouveler un petit peu les champions la
preuve ce que je crois c'est la
troisième fois que les arts que tu viens
donc c'est bien aussi de savoir un peu
l'historique du trophée sport passion
toutes ces années qu'on a passé ensemble
et puis un jour ou l'autre ces jeunes
aussi parleront des anciens et puis nous
on parlera des jeunes parce que philippe
donne l'exemple sur cette édition à 28e
édition mais bien sûr qui donne
l'exemple toujours il donne l'exemple de
toute façon je n'ai pas vu jouer par
contre donc ça je sais pas s'il a donné
l'exemple sur le exemple pour
démocratiser le golf du tout les
étiquettes qu'il faut mais je respecte
les golfeurs comme je respecte le
parcours mais en tout cas je suis pas là
pour me prendre la tête le golf ça doit
être un moment de détente c'est
exactement je pense qu'il a bien résumé
moment de détente de partager voilà on
est très très ravi et très heureux
d'être ici donc troisième participation
pour vous deux ans quand vous étiez au
paris saint germain et là c'est votre
grand retour c'est ça c'est le come back
qui après des années d'exil on va dire
entre guillemets mais oui c'était
compliqué pour moi de revenir avec les
entraînements et le boulot qui prend du
temps et surtout les déplacements quand
on est loin mais voilà dès que j'ai reçu
le petit mail d'invitation c'est avec un
grand plaisir que que j'ai souhaité
participer mais qu'est ce qui vous
séduit dans ce trophée sport passion
j'ai l'impression que c'est la bonne
humeur c'est ça ouais touba déjà
premièrement on fait on fait ce genre de
deux réunions pour ça c'est vrai qu'il
ya toujours un esprit bon enfant les
gens sont contents de se retrouver il ya
des supers animations qui sont mises en
place et puis à chaque fois c'est dans
un grand plaisir partagé donc on est
vraiment ravis de participer en fait ce
qui est bien c'est que le trophée sport
patients on remplace peut-être ce que ne
fait plus le ministère des sports le
cnosf c'est à dire c'est une rencontre
inter sportifs qui se sont pas vus
depuis des années des gens qui font de
la glace comme des sports d'hiver ou des
sports d'été qui se réunissent qui se
revoient ils sont contents on a une
bonne bouffe c'est vraiment la
convivialité qui prit donc 20 20 édition
s qui est un souvenir qui vous revient
en tête philippe pas pas plus que ça
parce qu'elle est partie de golf fils
mais ne se ressemblent pas parfois
heureusement mais en tout cas moi c'est
plus les photos on essaye toujours de se
réinventer puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
photographes qui traînent pendant la
journée de golf et on essaie de faire
des photos différentes chaque année je
n'arrivais pas y en a une que j'aimerais
bien revoir c'est une fois j'ai planté
un ti dans ma raie des fesses et avec
quelqu'un qui devait jouer comme ça
j'aimerais bien voir comparer mes fesses
d'il ya vingt ans et mes fesses
d'aujourd'hui n'ont cessé ces pâles ou
en tout cas je crois pas
demanderez
caméra j'avais juste fait la photo et du
coup est ce que vous allez revenir enfin
vous j'imagine que oui philippe mais
vous
évidemment rendez vous incontournable
non je suis pas très loin donc
évidemment tous les ans dans la mesure
du possible je serai présent avec un
grand plaisir est-ce que vous allez
viser le titre non ça c'était trop
compliqué pour des biens meilleurs jours
on s'en fiche en fait le titre c'est
juste le titre de comme l'a dit philippe
convivialité on s'amuse on partage de
bons moments on se retrouve et je pense
que ça n'a pas de prôner un temps
magnifique aujourd'hui alors cette année
c'est à ça se passe a bêtement
habituellement un aphte roll on reste
dans le 78 je crois qu'on l'a régine est
attaché aussi à son organisation et je
trouve que c'est beau d'avoir tenu 28
ans et on espère qu'elle va aller
jusqu'au 30 est ce qu'il y aura une
soirée ce soir peut-être j'ai entendu
dire que c'était pas mal les soirées ici
à c'est toujours agréable à partir du
moment où vous êtes entre bonne personne
qu'on s'amuse et on passe forcément des
bonnes soit regardé leur département du
78 qui nous accompagnent à l'ufolep avec
un super mur d'escaladé tourner on a de
quoi faire en fait moi je joue le matin
pour pouvoir faire d'après midi le poker
le concours de pilotage l'escaladé on a
des on a des petits challenge en fait
les uns entre les autres en dehors du
golfe vous passez une bonne journée quoi
bein génial d'ailleurs on va vous
quitter parce que le temps passé à
prendre part à toutes les activités
de l'est tous merci beaucoup merci au
coach de candeloro et on va regarder
maintenant le prochain un reportage et
concerne les triathlètes du club de
poissy ils ont gagné une très belle
médaille de bronze cet été aux jo de
tokyo ils sont revenus dans leur ville
de poissy regardez ce reportage
[Musique]
c'est la tête aujourd'hui à poissy trois
triathlètes de la ville sont venus
présenter leur médaille de bronze
acquise lors du relais mixte aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo leur nom d'orient
conax léonie perriot et cassante
beaugrand
c'est cool ça fait ça fait plaisir que
que les gens soient là et qu'ils aient
apprécié et que des qui nous supportent
ça fait un long moment maintenant
j'essaie vraiment jeune quand j'étais au
club donc ça fait vraiment plaisir de le
partager avec toutes ces personnes
justement
[Musique]
à mes côtés léonie perriot alors
l'ennemi perriot vous êtes on peut le
dire une illinoise où vous êtes
peut-être la plus illinoise de ce trio
alors qu'est ce que ça vous fait tout
simplement d'avoir vu autant de monde
aujourd'hui je crois avoir vu votre
maman aussi oui c'est ça bah c'est vrai
que ça fait bas ça fait très plaisir de
ramener la médaille à la ville c'est
vrai que bah c'est notre partenaire
phare donc ramener ça mon cas monsieur
le maire va tous les pisciacais ça fait
vraiment très plaisir alors qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette médaille de
bronze que vous avez autour du cou bah
c'est une belle récompense et c'était un
objectif donc pas de l'avoir fait c'est
grand c'est beau et ça fait très plaisir
alors c'est d'autant plus beau parce que
vous avez une crise d'appendicite c'est
ça juste avant de partir pour tokyo oui
bah déjà mais deux mois avant et donc
c'est en mai ces fameux c'était le jour
de la sélection donc après voilà dire
mais je me suis bien rétabli bas pour
être prête pour les jo et vous avez
terminé 5e en individuel est ce que
c'était espérée est ce que c'était un
rêve non mais c'est vrai que la course
individuelle c'était vraiment du bonus
parce que j'étais vraiment venu pour va
pour performer avec le relais donc c'est
vrai que ça s'est très bien déroulé donc
ça m'a vraiment bas mis sur les bons
rails pour pour l'épreuve collective ray
vous avez 27 ans est ce que vous sentez
que vous montez en puissance au fur et à
mesure des saisons bas pour l'instant
oui je progresse je progresse donc du
coup bah c'est ce qui motiverait il ya
paris 2024 un tout le monde vous en
parlait déjà de 1024 vous y serez vous
serez avec poissy évidemment web a bien
sûr oui mais enfin magie serait bien
j'espère ce que déjà mais faut se
qualifier et je serai à poissy ou et
bien sûr
pour les avoir vus performé les avoir
vus courir faire le vélo ou nager c'est
juste extraordinaire ce qu'ils ont
réalisé
[Musique]
j'ai une journée de reconnaissance je
crois de du travail accompli depuis ces
années et puis d'une consécration
suprême parce que moins une médaille
olympique ça ça reste quand même quelque
chose de très très très particulière il
a fallu aller convaincre alors
convaincre les partenaires convaincre
les élus convaincre aussi toutes celles
et ceux qui n'y croyaient pas forcément
et à force de patience à force de
conviction mais ce club aujourd'hui l'un
des meilleurs clubs d'europe
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler handball féminin
l'équipe de paris 92 dont tv 78 et
partenaires a présenté ce lundi 6
septembre son nouvel effectif dans ce
nouvel effectif on retrouve notamment
une championnes olympiques laura flippes
reportage
une nouvelle saison débute pour les
lionnes du paris 92 l'effectif désormais
au complet été officiellement présentée
à l'aube du premier match il aura pour
objectif de finir sur le podium après
avoir terminé dans le top-5 l'année
dernière les ambitions monde d'année en
année la halle forme de plus en plus
forte
on va maintenant commencer à aviser
avisés des titres tous les ans peut-être
pas forcément cette année mais en tout
cas on s'y prépare dans son effectif le
club pourra compter sur sa capitaine
yvelinoise deborah la source à 21 ans la
handballeuse originaire de maisons
laffitte est au club depuis sept ans
paris 92 comptera également dans ses
rangs une championne olympique en titre
avec laura flippes l'une des meilleures
joueuses françaises à tokyo cet été
forcément j'ai envie de faire une belle
saison j'ai envie d'aider l'équipe au
maximum et qu'on en fasse de bons
résultats cette saison je pense que ça
change beaucoup pour elle mais c'est
vrai que pour nous on est très fier très
contente pour elle mais ça reste une
aventure de sélection et non en club
donc on espère justement gagner des
titres avec elle au total le club pourra
compter sur quatorze joueuses
professionnelles et des jeunes du centre
de formation un effectif plus étoffé que
les dernières années ça me permet de
pouvoir amener certaines josette fraîche
dans les moments importants du match ça
me permet également de diversifier les
formes de jeu donc effectivement pour un
coach c'est très intéressant d'avoir
autant d'options lors de leur premier
match de la saison ce mercredi 8
septembre les lyonnais l'ont emporté 29
à 22 contre chambre est de bonne augure
pour la suite de la saison course à pied
à présent ils ont souffert ce samedi en
septembre lors de la diac 78 des trailer
ont traversé le département du nord au
sud reportage
l arrivée premier débrief pour le trio
de tête de cette diag 78 cette deuxième
édition de ce trait il a vu alexandre
bouchex l'emporté sur cette traversée du
nord au sud du département le trailer de
29 ans surnommé casquette verte termine
6h23 et quarante et une secondes sur le
84 km j'ai super content une victoire
c'est toujours c'est toujours un plaisir
mais je suis content aussi parce que ça
fait plaisir de pouvoir couvrir des
grandes distances comme ça
83 ou 85 km en ile de france cette année
trois distances étaient au programme 84
km 44 km et 20 km
la course la plus longue est parti le
matin de breuil bois robert pour arriver
à rochefort en yvelines l'objectif des
organisateurs est avant tout de faire un
coup de projecteur sur le département
quand même le territoire est magnifique
l'idée ce serait de faire une traversée
de ce département qui est magnifique et
de renier les petits villages entre eux
et c'était ça notre démarche de faire
découvrir les yvelines une recette qui
fonctionne après une première édition à
300 participants cette année ils étaient
plus de 550 au départ c'est une chouette
course en fait pour ça permet de voir
plein de choses le départ à 7h au lever
du soleil c'est vraiment chouette et
puis il ya les beaux paysages de la fin
lavez les dix derniers kilomètres sont
vraiment c'est vraiment très jolie
dessus de rochefort on a des beaux
points de vue c'est autre chose que de
la montagne mais c'est un autre exercice
et c'est vraiment sympa à faire
on prend tout autant de plaisir à faire
une diagonale ici que diagonale des fous
la diact 60,18 reviendra l'année
prochaine pour une troisième édition le
parcours devrait être similaire
on commence cet agenda part du tennis
c'est le rendez vous à ne pas manquer si
vous êtes un passionné de ce sport le
tennis club de plaisir organise son
traditionnel tournoi international à
futur dans ses locaux
regardez ce reportage
[Applaudissements]
le concept de ce tournoi c'est un
tournoi international c'est le seul
tournoi de cette catégorie en ile de
france
doté de 25 mille dollars avec les
encouragements de la fédération
française de tennis
tu m'a octroyé ce créneau depuis de
nombreuses années il ya des noms quand
même prestigieux qui ont gagné mon tour
noire les llodra il ya du beau monde
donc il ya des grands champions qui sont
passés par là forcément ce sont des
stations comme on dirige incontournable
pour ces joueurs qui veulent devenir
professionnel
nous avons les premiers joueurs qui sont
à re centièmes à l'atp donc ce sont des
joueurs professionnels voire semi
professionnel et qui sont là pour adam
obtenir des points à l'atp et ensuite
s'inscrire dans des tournois plus
importants comme deux des grands chelems
où des challengers
et j'espère d'abord que cela va bien se
passer que les joueurs vont pas ce que
c'est les joueurs vont disputer là avec
beaucoup de 2,2 à rien donc on va avoir
des matches fabuleux au tennis-club de
plaisir l'entrée est gratuite pour tout
le monde on exige seulement le pain
sanitaires bien évidemment pour
respecter le protocole sanitaire en
vigueur
mais sinon l'entrée gratuite et en
espère voir du monde pour déguster si je
puis dire chez match plus intéressant en
athlétisme le galli athletic club et sa
section locale du plaisir athletic club
et la ville de plaisir organise leur
tout premier meeting d'athlétisme
l'événement est programmé ce 18
septembre à partir de 12h30 au programme
des épreuves de 200 m 1500 m 1 400 m 1
5000 m la manifestation se tiendra au
stade bernard geoa plaisir
et avant de refermer cette émission nous
sommes avec l'inde et l'une des
personnalités à de ce trophée sport
passion samir ait said vous êtes avec
nous vous revenez tout juste de tokyo
pourquoi vous avez voulu participer à ce
trophée sport passion bas déjà parce que
c'est un événement que j'apprécie
énormément j'ai la chance d'être invitée
depuis depuis quelques années c'est
toujours un moment très agréable une
petite famille on se retrouve entre
sportifs ou même une autre sportif voilà
en échange on fait des initiations au
golf moi qui suis pas du tout golfeur
bas ça fait depuis dix ans que je suis à
l'initiation non mais voilà c'est pour
ça c'est vraiment une très bonne
ambiance et et ça nous permet de se
retrouver d'échanger vous avez pu tester
quand même un petit peu les parcours ou
pas du tout non pas encore bas
malheureusement je me suis fait une
petite déchirure au biceps au jeu donc
là je vais pas tenter le diable même si
ça me ça me démange un petit peu mais
non là je suis en plein soins donc
falloir rester sérieux et on fera ça
l'année prochaine très rapidement
comment ça s'est passé tokyo vous étiez
à porte drapeau super expérience ou
déception par rapport au résultat vous
n'avez pas pu obtenir une médaille alors
bas les deux déjà une expérience de
folie en étant porte drapeau ça a été
tout simplement magnifique après bombe à
la petite désillusion parce que ben je
finis quatrième au pied du podium à
cause à cause de moi tout simplement je
vais pas dire à cause de la blessure
parce que c'est pas le cas mais voilà ce
qui est difficile c'est que aux qualifs
j'étais sur le podium et le jour de ma
finale j'ai pas pu m'exprimer comme
comme je le voulais comme je le
souhaitais et du coup je
j'échoue à la quatrième place elle fait
d'être porte drapeau c'était quand même
un bon souvenir à ça a été
extraordinaire honnêtement ça a été ça
sera gravé à vie dans ma tête et voilà
c'est toute une fierté de porter tout un
pays voilà un pays tout une délégation
france derrière et voilà c'est des
choses qui arrivent qu'une fois dans sa
vie bon pour les prochaines années il ya
le trophée sport passion peut être que
vous irez sur le parcours à bientôt mais
il ya également les jo-2000 24 qui
approche très vite exactement on en est
à
presque 3 en moins de trois ans donc du
coup bah voilà on se soigne on va
repartir à fond aux entraînements pour
aller chercher ce titre olympique à la
maison à domicile voilà écrire un
des livres 1 belfort pardon du livre
merci beaucoup samir ait said c'est déjà
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro sur tv à 78
[Musique]